that's right my last review which was
for the movie incarnate you guys let me
know what you thought of incarnate you
comment below and you let me know that I
should talk about the lives of a Sutra I
talk about the lives opposed to each
other
meanwhile stranger things and Luke Cage
fans of all things in their time - I'm
just saying there's a difference between
a minute and a half long trailers owner
talked about it in a 13 hour marathon of
Netflix or television then I talked
about it in a world brothers never
enough time which is coincidentally the
same world where I loved the Last of Us
let's talk about this trailer how much
to talk about really the trailer is very
short but there are things to be notice
it's really Elly strumming a guitar go
to Ed Wood people come at me I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill some folk but you see she's
got prison tats she's a little older
she's a little more hard and of course
dead people in the house because I guess
some people came after her and she laid
some folks out Dadar she straight-up
hunted them down and laid some folks out
you don't know by implication like Joel
comes in he just walk in and you see a
silhouette he's walking by some dead ass
bodies freshly dead - but there's still
blood running down Ellie's face while
she strumming guitar Joe comes in he's
like what are you doing kid takes a
guitarist like me the circle be unbroken
he doesn't do that but no he's like
you're really gonna go through with this
and she's like I'm going to kill every
last one of them which is very open to
interpretation what's it mean someone
wronged her is it like the people from
the first one there are some people that
wronged deli in the first one most of
those folks did not make it out okay so
there's are there remnants from the
first game that now it's just like not
screw that let's go after it let's kill
them let's actively hunt them down or is
she mean like I'm going to kill every
last one of the people who come after me
are the people who know that she has
some sort of cure in her blood I feel
like I'm spoiling the first Last of Us
game free just sorry if I am but if you
haven't played the first last of his
game why are you watching me talk about
a trailer for the second game do
yourself a favor go play The Last of Us
holy [ __ ] or is it the beginning of this
game someone wrongs her something
happens and she's like you know what
revenge quest let's go do that
I just know Ellie has an axe to grind
with some people and some folks in this
trailer paid for it a few minutes prior
I did notice that her tattoo is covering
up to bite on her arm that she had
because in this world if you have a bite
on your arm and you don't look like you
came fresh off of the Dutchmen in the
second Pirates of the Caribbean movie
you probably have a cure in your blood
that people will try to rip out of your
spine so in an attempt to have a
drama-free life she has covered up the
bite with tattoo
I guess which clearly didn't work out
for her because she's covered in spots
of blood singing a ballad of revenge
over a corpse a simple post-apocalyptic
life judging by this trailer I would not
be surprised if Elly is the star of the
next game not Joel the first game Joel
was the one you play as Ellie was
support maybe they're going a different
direction was like Ellie's the one you
play as Joel is support maybe you can
switch between bud that'd be pretty cool
Dunst the main one one support and then
you just push a button and then you swap
to the other one and now that's the main
one the other ones support you have to
work together with them now a few years
older like I said she's got attacks I
feel like in the next game she could
really hold her own and possibly carry
the game if they really need her to not
necessarily what I want to happen cuz I
love Joel and I want to play as Joel
also I do feel like if they have both
characters and you swap between the two
at your behest when you want to I think
that would be a really cool mechanic but
I mean let's not go nuts here I would
just all speculation I love trailers
like that I love movie trailers like
this I love game trailers like this
where it's just conceptual it's the
concept there's a personal moment with a
character there's some tone there's some
atmosphere there are a couple of bits of
dialogue couple words exchanged and then
the music cues up and gives you
goosebumps from here down your spine
because that's what it did that's
exactly how it went down for me so
anyhow the last of us to trailer this is
a collaborative effort here we were all
on the same page on this files like I
want to talk about that read my Twitter
feed and the comments of my previous
video I was like add they water here we
talk about this is me John on about the
lives of his - trailer looks pretty
[ __ ] awesome ain't gonna lie to you
I'm ready to kill some more folks ready
to kill some infected - but come on the
real animals in this thing it's two
people 20 how the last of us to trailer
that they just unveiled have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here that say more
[Music]